la connaissait depuis plusieurs années
c'était ma soeur je les connais par
l'entremise de travail c'est une
personne très très très très sociable je
voyage avec l attirer les gens c'est un
spécialiste des années oui ah oui disney
la capitale hâtives c'est une personne
qui était dans un moment de sa vie où
était vraiment très épanouie
[Musique]
je le côtoyais quand même
pierre pinon même si jeune fille le kiss
méfie ou ce genre de choses ne jamais je
l' ai vu venir c'est vraiment pas facile
parce que ces personnes là n'ont pas
juste des mauvais côtés un rayon des
bons côtés aussi c'est avec les bons
côtés qui sont capables de vraiment dans
dans dans tout allait alors je leur
victime lui a créé plein de cadeaux on
l'a connue par l'entremise du seul fait
qu'on sortait souvent bateaux et les
fables sur fès et des moments qui était
joyeux ce que ça à l'automne on va
commencer à sentir vraiment des
consignes aux danses ans si tu peux pas
ta vie comme ça tu peux pas sortir avec
les faits je pouvais voir un peu le type
de personne que c'était mais de là à
aller où est-ce que var qu'est ce qui
s'est passé non je n'ai jamais pu penser
ça j'ai commencé à vraiment plus s'ils
s'affirment et puis séparés christine un
petit peu de de ce garçon mais
sérieusement ça s'est fait tellement de
manière sournoise le wask des bailleurs
bon fond qui fait pas les choses pour
être méchant mais une fois qu'on associe
ou raboutou ces moments là on se rend
compte que tu pas que c'était des cinq
domaines place cette affaire
[Musique]
moment donné j'ai eu à un coup au gym
textron dell qui me disait que c'était
terminé
donc on pouvait pas à pouvait pas
continuer avec une personne comme ça
c'était c'était poignée sur une affaire
de contrôle par rapport à mai 5 juin
puis après kouamé dit qu'il l'avait à
côté dames c'est qu'elle a voulu prendre
des choses place s'en aller je sois moi
tu les avais donné aux livres elle lui
le les huîtres donc c'était un livre sur
les lits pervers narcissique et a
vraiment donné elle me dit annie à 10
parce qu'il ya tout les critères qui
sont décrits dans le livre comme il est
un même plat par six mois je ne le
croyais pas le chemin non ça se peut pas
j'adorerais pasteur fait que jared pas
être le seul à prendre celle c'est quand
qu'il est venu la chercher
mir venu la chercher vers le mois de fin
septembre octobre
là j'ai vu vraiment une distance qui
s'est installé entre elle et moi c'est
comme une mission qu'elle a changé c'est
qu'elle allait vraiment par la
différence qu'elle allait on m'a changé
difficile de faire voir à quelqu un
quelque chose qu'elle ne veut pour vous
en elle aurait été violenté à
l'intérieur de la chambre d'hôtel j'y
croyais pas je l'appelais constamment
puis je croyais pas je peux pas la
pression on voit plein de choses qui
sont ex conjointe des gens qui
communiquent avec moi qui parle aux
personnages qui le sait le choc
c'est là le choc parce que il y aurait
fallu qu'on le voit il aurait fallu que
ces choses le soit connu avant ça
l'aurait peut-être fait une différence
je ressens beaucoup de culpabilité le
para para sans jamais pouvoir la voir
pouvoir par la différence étant donné qu
était j'étais une des rares à pouvoir
les fréquenter dans leur côté avoir
accès
je t'aime la pierre dans son intimité
dans sa maison et consorts mais pau on
sent mais peut on apprend à vivre avec